donna are we on schedule for the tent
setup the table showed up which is good
but there are no chairs which is bad
okay well
get some chairs from somewhere
great leadership inspiring oh
god leslie was gonna go on pawnee today
to promote the gala
i'll do it no offense wrong but i don't
think you'd be great on tv
i can speak in full sentences and i
won't cry
fair point i did cry last time godspeed
i'm here for the interview about
tonight's gala yeah listen i'm a little
under the weather went on a boost cruise
last week
just finished up an hour ago on a
completely unrelated note
i have horrible allergies sorry to hear
that ah
but i do need to promote this event well
don't worry about me i'm a true
professional the show
must go on two hello
i'm joan callamezzo today's
show will not go on
seems like her allergies are kicking in
my name is ron swanson i'm here to tell
you about a black tie gala fundraiser
for pawnee commons happening tonight
all proceeds will go toward building a
park it will be enjoyable
oh take a take a phone call now i will
take your calls apparently
yes hey joan settle a bet for me who's
the sexiest couple in history
our pat's in k-stew or bieber
hey how's it going uh well this
simulated disaster is a total disaster
how are you ron subbed for you on pawnee
today
ron who ron swanson on television you
know we want
people to come right shouldn't you be
taking her to lie down somewhere
oh no if she ever found out that we took
her off camera we'd all be fired
so just uh keep taking phone calls
you're doing great three two
hello again i'm ron swanson and i am
still
taking your calls hopefully about
tonight's gala
you're on the air hi uh what's wrong
with joan
she has a bad hangover which she is
pretending as allergies
is she gonna be okay wouldn't know never
been hung over
after i've had too much whiskey i cook
myself a large flank steak pan-fried and
salted butter i eat that put on a pair
of wet socks and go to sleep
that works it does please call now if
you have questions about tonight's gala
or one of my other interests woodworking
uh novels about tall ships meat
that sort of thing this is ron go ahead
caller
hi my yorkshire terrier has chewed up
the legs on my kitchen table
is there a cheap way to repair that
great question
take a walnut and rub it into the legs
of your table that'll mask the scratches
next thing you want to do is ditch the
terrier and get yourself a proper dog
any dog under 50 pounds is a cat and
cats are pointless
come to the gala next caller grapes of
wrath
chocolate chip ice cream and johnny cash
don't trust big banks or small banks
banks or ponzi schemes run by morons
your house isn't haunted you're lonely
whatever happened to
hey i have some apples would you like to
buy them yes thank you
that's as complicated as it should be to
open a business in this country
i've seen three movies in my life bridge
on the river kwai
patton and herbie fully loaded my
girlfriend's kids love it
it's pretty funny next caller
good morning
you